russia and ukraine united in rivalry
in the interview kremlin critic and
former oligarch michael korkowski
let's start with the situation in
ukraine
at the recent d-day commemorations in
france
there were informal meetings between u.s
president barack obama
russia's vladimir putin
and petro poroshenko the newly elected
ukrainian president the german polish
and russian foreign ministers also met
in saint petersburg the west sees this
as a step towards possible rapprochement
what's your assessment
i'm convinced there must be negotiations
the situation in ukraine is serious
enough
but president putin has also maneuvered
himself into a most delicate and
complicated predicament
he
is there any possibility that the
kremlin can somehow come to terms with
the new government in kiev
or will the threat of draconian
sanctions somehow force russia's hand
there's no doubt that he has a whole
series of measures that he wants to
impose on ukraine
and if kiev accept them putin will put
an end to some of the pressures he's
been exerting
might help to correct putin's demands
with the result of an acceptable outcome
for both sides
but i'm not 100 convinced that sanctions
are the best motivators
if ukraine really desires freedom and
sovereignty
it must be willing to fight for them
the russian president's overriding goal
is pursuing the vision of a eurasian
union his response to the european union
a kind of counterbalance
and to make the dream a reality putin
needs ukraine or at least part of it
is that his prime motivation
the problem is that his strategy for
ukraine has spawned massive negative
consequences for russia uh
russia is a very attractive country
in eurasia it's the recognized leader in
terms of technology and science
russia should exploit these advantages
we could have formed alliances with our
neighbours that would strengthen all
sides
economic relations are fairly solid with
most eurasian nations
but that's mostly due to the sheer lack
of alternatives
but since ukraine
diplomatic relations with these
countries have deteriorated drastically
tensions are high throughout the region
and mistrust has grown exponentially
mistrust both of russia and ethnic
russians who live in those countries
prime examples are the baltic states
this is directly tied to putin's
policies
it may sound unfair but my opinion is
justified
vladimir putin has made broad promises
but has delivered very little
he has duped millions of russians
what about crimea
it's clear russia won't hand it back to
ukraine and the west refuses to
recognize the annexation
will crimea remain a thorn in the side
of relations between russia and the
western alliance
i'm convinced that russia and ukraine
must find a way to work together
and in relations with europe
i want to hear your opinion about the
clash of cultures
and about the apparent rejection of the
western lifestyle
i'm talking about tolerance of
alternative sexuality freedom of speech
individuality and egotism
can russian society accept these values
russians are every bit as much
individualists as the citizens of
western europe
can't go so far as to say that a
collective spirit is far more widespread
in the west
that is precisely the problem we
russians have
we simply can't unite even when it comes
to finding solutions to contentious
issues
it is vitally important to formulate
alliances
independent of government power brokers
seamlessly into western society with
ease
you'll find no russian china towns no
russian districts in western cities
there are so many russians who believe
in themselves in their ability to
compete and in their inherent strengths
they understand that russia is a part of
europe and they also recognize their
status as equals with europe
russia will not tolerate being treated
as a small child
russian culture is closely tied with
europe
without russian influence european
culture would be entirely different
you've also said that the vast majority
of russians are afraid to speak their
minds what can be done to combat the
government-run media
at the moment we don't have too many
alternatives
it's vital that our citizens are well
informed
and putin's regime understands that it
can only retain control of important
information
when that control is exerted
russian television is completely under
government
but print media is increasingly under
pressure as well
and there have been attempts to regulate
the internet too
much
let's say it builds a functioning
vibrant democracy based on law and order
with u.s and european support
how would that affect russia
would it be seen as an opportunity or a
threat
it would be wonderful to see a
prosperous and satisfied ukraine
especially since we have such close ties
it might function as a paradigm a
precedent
people so close to us in terms of
language and culture that have achieved
success
building the foundations of democracy
that outcome could truly provide a
blueprint for similar renewal in russia
pride
i want to see
thank you